this video is kindly sponsored by
morning brew the free daily newsletter
hey 42 here your childhood experiences
will have depended heavily on when and
where you grew up having spent my
formative years in england during the
early 2000s i naturally had to do
regular battle with roaming gangs of
tracksuit wearing chavs
in between frantically updating my bibo
profile all while sticking to the
government mandated minimum of four cups
of tea a day of course
but there's one part of childhood that
seems to remain consistent no matter
when or where you grew up
urban legends
those stories about a friend of a
friend's cousin
who had his organs harvested whilst on a
family holiday in skegness
or a kid at your school who went missing
in the changing rooms after pe and was
never seen again
tales like these are passed around
children like brightly coloured pills at
an all-night rave but as we grow up most
of us slowly realize one simple
unavoidable truth
urban legends are exactly that
legends stories told by kids with
overactive imaginations that get
embellished with every retelling so to
clear things up saying candyman into a
mirror five times is about as dangerous
as a salad slenderman looks pretty
creepy
but was actually made up during a
photoshop competition in 2009
and there are precisely zero species of
spider that can lay eggs underneath
human skin
but what happens when an urban legend
stops being a story told only by
children
what if the adults start believing too
well
that's when you need to start worrying
this is the story of the north pond
hermit an urban legend
that came true
before morning break i used to spend my
morning scrolling through various social
media aimlessly looking for something to
stimulate my sleepy neurons but i often
find myself looking at the same
monotonous news as the day before now
with the morning brew i can be up to
date with all the latest business tech
and finance news in just 5 minutes
morning brew is just the perfect way to
start your day there's no dense and
tedious articles just relevant
informative updates written in a
refreshing and witty narrative the
newsletter is delivered daily from
monday through to sunday so you're
always reading new content day to day
just the other day on morning brew i
learnt that in june of this year the u.s
housing market was up a staggering 22.9
from the previous year and there's
speculation by some economist that the
housing market may have just peaked and
we could be in for a fall in prices in
coming months so if you're interested in
business tech or finance like i am
there's really no reason not to
subscribe to morningbro it's completely
free and takes less than 15 seconds
and to make it even easier you can just
go ahead and click the link in the
description to subscribe today
maine is considered by many to be one of
the more boring us states
a place where not a lot happens to not a
lot of people
but four residents who lived in the
community around north pond over the
last 35 years or so
life has been anything but dull
and the reason for that
is simple their peaceful rural existence
has been plagued by
something a phantom that stalked the
woods around their community
slipping into their houses in the dead
of night and
changing things
clothes would go missing
food and camping supplies too
along with keys and random bits and
pieces from the kitchen
now that might not sound all that odd
after all petty crime happens pretty
much everywhere in the world all the
time in the u.s alone a burglary was
committed on average once every 28
seconds in 2019
the break-ins around north pond were of
course unsettling but sadly nothing out
of the ordinary in the modern world
and that's what the local residents
fought too
at first
but this spate of mysterious break-ins
continued not just for a few weeks or
months not even for a few years
whatever it was that was lurking in the
dense forests around north pond had been
spiriting its way into people's homes
for decades
and surely no petty criminal could go
undetected in a small rural community
for that long
it wasn't just the longevity of the
crime spree either it was the sheer
volume of incidents that caused the
hairs on people's necks to stand on end
as a community meeting in the early
2000s local residents were asked to
raise their hands if their homes had
been broken into by the phantom
a staggering 75 percent of people put
their hands in the air whatever was
preying on their community it seemed
almost supernatural in nature a prolific
poltergeist with a punch-on for canned
food and old clothes
that was never seen or heard over time
this presence was given a name
the north pond hermit
and
a modern urban legend was born
some truly believed in this shadowy
figure believed that someone or perhaps
something
lived in the woods around the lake
never seen
never heard only detectable through
those odds and ends that seem to go
missing every now and then
the more stoic of the north pond
residents on the other hand were
skeptical putting the break-ins down to
a combination of local kids getting up
to no good and forgetful residents
invoking the hermit whenever they
misplaced an old t-shirt in the laundry
room
one of those who firmly believed the
north pond hermit was real was game
warden sergeant terry hughes in fact he
was so convinced a creature existed that
he decided he was going to try and catch
it
he bought motion-activated camera traps
and hid them in one of the local summer
camps thought to be a frequent haunt of
the hermit sergeant hughes carefully
arranged the cameras in the camp store
room which was packed with the kinds of
odds and ends the hermit was known to be
fond of then rigged the cameras so
they'd trigger an alarm in his own home
if they detected movement
then
he waited
one day in the spring of 2013
the alarm began to ring
we don't know what sergeant hughes
expected to find as he raced towards the
camp in his truck after all it isn't
every day you come face to face with a
phantom
a genuine urban legend that's been
around long enough that kids have had
time to grow up and pass on their
stories to their own children but what
sergeant hughes did find
wasn't some kind of monster or ghost
the north pond hermit was just a man
but in many ways
his story turned out to be
more fantastical than the ones local
residents had dreamt up over the decades
christopher thomas knight had gone into
the woods around the north pond back in
the 80s
and
he'd stayed there alone
for 28 years
simply living off the land and of course
the unwitting generosity of north pond's
residents
it's estimated christopher committed
around a thousand robberies of the
houses around the lake during this time
stealing the things he needed to stay
alive
judged on the number of offenses alone
the north pond hermit
may well be one of the most prolific
burglars of all time
it's really quite hard to get your head
around this man's existence
he disappeared off the face of the earth
just after the chernobyl disaster in
1986 and had almost no contact with the
outside world
until after his discovery by sergeant
terry hughes in 2013.
as a result he knew nothing of the
internet smartphones social media 911 or
the fall of the berlin wall and during
the decades in which these world
altering events and technologies came
and went
christopher knight claimed to have
spoken to another human being
on only two occasions
once to say hi to a hiker he crossed his
path sometime in the 90s and once to
three fishermen he stumbled across his
camp just two months before he was
captured
aside from that for close to three
decades
he never heard another human voice in
our world of smartphones and 24-hour
news channels
that's actually pretty hard to get your
head around
seriously what's the longest you've ever
gone without speaking
i'm guessing it's a day or two at most
of course christopher knight isn't the
only person to ever shut himself off
from society in fact we humans have been
doing it for centuries
but whilst he may not be the first the
north pond hermit is still kind of
unique
after all most people who walk away from
the world do so either for religious
reasons
as a kind of protest against injustices
in society
or because they're high fatul in arty
types who think that manufactured
solitude will feed their creativity but
christopher knight went into the wild
for none of these reasons
in fact it seems as though
he didn't really have a reason at all
one day at the age of 20 he just
wandered off into the main countryside
and he simply never came back
until his capture at the age of 48. he
went into the forest with basically
nothing no equipment for cooking or
catching food no map or compass no
survival gear just a tent and an empty
rucksack in their 20s 30s and 40s most
people set about climbing the ladder in
their chosen career starting families
seeing the world or doing any number of
the thousands of other little things
that make up your average human life
christopher knight simply watched a
world go by from a distance
he stumbled upon the camping spot that
would become his home for almost 30
years completely by chance
tucked away in an impossibly dense
thicket of trees between a bunch of
glacial erratics
those are large boulders moved into odd
positions by the actions of glaciers the
camp was only an hour's hike from the
nearest human habitation but it was so
well hidden that none of the locals had
any idea it even existed
to say that christopher knight is a
polarizing figure would be a bit of an
understatement
some people see him as a sort of hero a
man who left the madness of the modern
world behind to live the kind of simple
existence our early ancestors might have
lived just with a lot more thievery
but others see only a criminal a man who
quite literally terrorized an entire
community for decades
it's true that he never broke into
houses when people were home and that he
certainly never caused anyone any direct
harm
but there's a bit more to it than that
for close to 30 years he made hundreds
of people feel uneasy in their homes he
took care never to be seen but the north
pond hermit
the specter in the woods
was very real to those who lived around
the lake whatever your take one thing
nobody can deny is that christopher
knight was in possession of some pretty
remarkable survival skills anyone who's
visited maine in the winter will know
just how cold it gets up there
temperatures can easily plummet to minus
30 degrees celsius it gets warmer than
that on a nice day in the antarctic
literally
these are temperatures that can kill
even experienced and well-equipped
campers
and yet christopher knight lived in a
cobbled together camp with limited
equipment
and never built fires for fear of the
smoke giving him away
he made it through these impossibly cold
winters
decade after decade by training himself
to wake up during the coldest part of
the night so that he could pace around
his camp to generate body heat
he's a bit like wim hof but without the
pr team christopher's story is a
remarkable one in many ways
and it sort of makes you wonder who else
might be hidden away in forgotten
corners of the planet living on the
fringes of society just out of sight
something to think about the next time
you check the fridge and
can't find the leftover lasagna you'd
swear was in there just yesterday
thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcasts you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break
you're welcome